-My first guest
is a great actress.
You can see her as Wonder Woman
in the new movie
"Wonder Woman 1984."
It's in select theaters
and IMAX on Christmas Day
and will also be available
the same day on HBO Max.
Here is Gal Gadot!
Gal!
Oh, my goodness.
It's so good to --
-We're hugging you from here.
-I'm hugging you from here, too.
Oh, pal, it's so great
to see you.
Thank you so much
for coming back to our show.
Can you believe
"Wonder Woman 1984"
is finally here?
It's here, it's happening.
-I can and I can't
at the same time.
We've been waiting
for such a long time
to be able to share this
with the world
and now is the moment.
And it's so surreal
that we're releasing the movie,
and I don't get to see you.
Like, everything is virtual.
The world had gone crazy.
-I know, but it's a great --
-I'm super excited.
-I want to say that this movie
has more action
than the first one.
Did you know that going into it
that you're gonna be like,
"I'm going to be exhausted
in this one"?
-Yes, I did.
Patty made a big point about
wanting to have
minimum amount of CGI,
which is great,
and I love the idea.
I just didn't really understood
what it meant for me,
and what it did mean
was that we just --
you know, both Kristen, too,
and I had to do so much --
so much stunt work by ourselves.
-I want to show you one thing
that I noticed
when I watched it.
There was one kick that you did
that I want to say --
-Oh, that.
-Your body was like --
You were parall--
-The front kick --
The front kick layout.
-The front kick layout
is what it's called?
-It's horizontal and --
-Were you on wires?
-That was assisted majorly,
and that was also my stunt girl,
who's, like, amazing.
-I asked the studio
for this clip
'cause I just wanted
to watch it.
Do you mind
if I watch this kick?
Dave, could we watch this?
-Sure.
-Yeah, let's watch it.
-Look at this.
Stop right there.
Look at that.
Look at that!
Perfection!
-[ Laughing ]
-That is unbelievable!
-And holding the gun
and the lasso.
-And the lasso.
I mean, look at that.
That's the poster right there.
Come on.
I also remember
seeing something.
I thought it was you flying in
the invisible jet or something.
I thought that was a spoiler
or something,
'cause it looked like you were
sitting in the street.
-I know, I know.
That was not the invisible jet.
That was me being in major pain.
We shut down Penn Avenue
in Washington, D.C.,
for a few days,
and I had to do, like,
this intense running,
and I was wired, like,
from here and from here,
and they pulled me
in the same speed as Usain Bolt
ran when he won
one of his medals.
-He's the fastest man
in the world.
-Yeah, I know.
So we had to --
So that's what we did.
-So that was you --
Oh, so you needed --
'Cause you're actually running
and the wires are pulling you.
-But the craziest thing is
that you got to make sure
that every stride,
you hit the floor
so it does look like
you're running.
-Yeah, I auditioned,
and, yeah, I didn't --
They actually didn't even
call me back at all,
but whatever.
A little rude, but...
I will say our pal Kristen Wiig
crushes it in this movie.
She's also in the movie.
-Crushes it.
We actually adore each other
so much.
We had a crazy
instant connection.
It was like she --
Because the movie was so
laborious and they were so --
It was very long.
We shot the movie
for eight months
in five different locations,
and it was just, like,
super physical, as well.
The fact that
she was there with me,
doing these crazy things
but also, like, being her,
she's, like, the most --
She's so --
You know, but she's like --
I'll tell everyone else.
Guys, you're missing on
not knowing Kristen Wiig.
-[ Laughing ]
-She's, like, fun and funny
and open, and, like,
she made this experience
so, so delightful for me,
and I'm super grateful.
-We know that you guys
became fast friends
and really good friends
on the set,
and this is very, very cool.
You guys sent us
one of your music videos.
You made a music video together.
It's very low-budget.
Here is an exclusive
world premiere of Gal Gadot
and Kristen Wiig's music video.
Take a look.
[ Rhythmic clapping ]
-♪ Gal and Krissy having fun ♪
♪ We're Gal and Krissy,
and we're having fun ♪
-♪ Sometimes we run
and jump in the air ♪
-♪ Sometimes we stare
and then flip our hair ♪
-♪ We are friends,
and we like science ♪
-♪ We feel comfortable
in total silence ♪
[ Insects chirping ]
-♪ Come on, everybody ♪
-♪ Dance in the sun ♪
♪ 'Cause we're Gal and Krissy ♪
♪ And we're having fun ♪
[ Both laugh ]
-I love you!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh, my God!
[ Children cheering ]
It's the fake applause
at the end, and the kids.
It is honestly --
-Oh, my God.
-♪ And we're having fun ♪
♪ Gal and Krissy,
and we're having fun ♪
Dude, that's catchy.
-The claps and everything.
-That was the funniest thing.
Can you tell everyone what's
going on in "Wonder Woman 1984"?
-Oh, my God.
Um...
Wow. Where do I begin without
giving away too many spoilers?
What I can tell you is,
it's the most ambitious movie
I've ever got to make.
As far as storytelling, we have
four different storylines.
As far as the action goes,
like we talked about,
there's so much action,
for real.
As far as location
and the scope, it's huge.
And I'm very, very excited
to share it with everybody.
And I hope that people
are going to enjoy it
and have a wonderful
2 1/2 hours watching it.
-We need it right now
more than ever.
I want to show everyone
a clip from the film.
Here's Gal Gadot
in "Wonder Woman 1984."
Take a look.
♪♪
-Well, aren't you resourceful.
-Come with me.
-No, I don't think so.
Remove this woman, please --
permanently.
[ Gunshots ]
-Aah!
[ Both grunting ]
Ow.
-Are you okay?
-I am now.
♪♪
[ Grunts ]
-Unh!
-"Wonder Woman 1984" will be
in select theaters and IMAX
on Christmas Day
and will be available
the same day on HBO Max.